un peu plus bas et stéphane verrue c'est
l'histoire d'un coup quand il débarque
sur l'île voilà dix ans le groupe
touristique en est à ses débuts à la
fois le payer s'ouvrait sur l'économie
sur l'investissement étranger
le tourisme comme celle des femmes et
tours opérators dans des voyages clés en
main à des agents sont comme tout chef
d'entreprise étrangers est bas il est
associé à une entreprise d'état et c'est
elle qui emploie officiellement les onze
salariés cubain recruté comme des femmes
un personnel discipline et socialisme
oublient qu'ils sont encadrés
politiquement angles a fortement et
qu'on le veuille ou pas ça ça a des
conséquences directes sur leur travail
ils sont ils se rattrapent discipline
qui en fait donne des résultats et
employer des cubains c'est c'est
vraiment fantastique en là on a jamais
de problème
les employés payés au lance-pierre par
l'état cubain moins de 10 euros mensuels
le salaire moyen ici stéphane leur
versant plus de 300 à 600 euros chaque
mois ils appellent ça y est c'est parti
motivé personnel comme promis les
responsabilités entre ce que effet pêché
fond
au contact des occidentaux mais que leur
candidat prg dans ce restaurant de la
vieille havane
sa femme vient d'initier une réservation
pour un client pour lui le régime
castriste c'est presque converti au
capitalisme
j'ai l'impression que parra que même des
fois ils sont plus capitaliste que nous
quelle façon par exemple
pragmatisme une façon c'est
tiroir caisse avant tout et le tourisme
c'est une ak finale puis a franchi l'an
dernier le cap des 2 millions de visites
au total ils sont une petite trentaine
de français à s'être installée à cuba
tous attendent maintenant la reprise des
investissements
après leur échauffement janvier dernier
des relations entre l'union européenne
et cuba